Dr. Kevin Cutters, and we are going to go over our ketogenic type diet. So if you have
a genetic predisposition of your cancer feeding off of the end point of glycolysis,
and I won't get into the details of that here, we talk about that in our genetic slides. But if through
the your genetic workout, I have said that more than likely due to different gene defects that
you have, that your cancer is being fed down through glycolysis, basically through glucose
intake, down through glycolysis and being fed off of lactic acid, then we're going to go on a
ketogenic like diet. So again, most people are on a mixed diet to begin with. When we get their
genetics back, we look at that and based upon that, I'm going to say, I need you on a low protein
diet, we're going to stay on a mixed diet, or we're going to go on a ketogenic like diet. There's
really three main diets for cancer patients, a low protein, low glutamate, low methaniety diet.
That's on another video. The mixed diet, which is going to stay on a whole food diet,
which is what I usually put most people on, or number three is this one right here, a ketogenic
type diet. A ketogenic type diet is based on trying to get your body to feed off of ketones instead
of glucose. Well, we don't need to get in a complete ketogenic state to really see us cut off
the fuel source for cancer. So that's why we call it a keto-like diet, a ketogenic like diet.
We're not going to be measuring ketone bodies in your blood. We're not going to have you get a
ketone meter. We're not going to measure ketones in your urine. We're looking at getting you
towards a ketogenic state. So that's what this is about. So let me explain how we go on a ketogenic
type diet. What's good and what's bad? First, it's important to understand a ketogenic food pyramid.
Now, there's a bunch of information on the internet on ketogenic diets. I'm not going to try to
reproduce all that. You can Google that. But basically, this is your new food pyramid. On the bottom
is what you eat the most of. On the top is what you eat the least of. So on a ketogenic diet,
you're eating a lot of healthy fats, coconut oil, butter, avocadoes, olive oil,
different herbs and spices, a lot of great vegetables, lots and lots of great vegetables,
and meat and eggs and fish, and fatty nuts. And then as you move up, you're starting to eat some
other vegetables too. You don't see a lot of root vegetables in there, do you? So you're not
eating a lot of root vegetables. They're more high in sugar. Yes, in a true ketogenic diet,
you can even eat some dairy. But that is dependent partly on your diet that I'm going to tell you
also, because dairy can be a mucus form, or it is a mucus form, or in a lot of people,
and we don't want to be using a lot of that. Now, butter may qualify as something that you can eat,
and this is going to be individual patient by patient. I'm giving you the basics here.
But as far as drinking milk and eating ice cream and stuff, those are out. Those are all sugar
things. So we don't want that. But you're getting an idea of a ketogenic food period. As far as
what you can drink, you're drinking water, you're drinking tea, you can make iced tea, you can put lemon
in your iced tea, you're drinking some coffee, and yes, you can even make the type of coffee where
you put coconut oil in it, blend it up, and that's called bulletproof coffee. You're not drinking alcohol.
Alcohol is like liquid sugar. It's completely non-beneficial to you. There's no benefits to that. So
if coffee doesn't bother your stomach, it fits that bother you, that can actually be good for you.
But also we look at the genes of that, don't we? So if you have that defect, it's actually a defect
that you want to have. If you like coffee, you actually detox it quite well, and it can really
help stimulate a parasympathetic reaction. That's why we do coffee enemas as well.
Phase three, just really looking at more deeply. What can you eat on a low carb ketogenic like diet?
Well, again, you're basically eliminating carbohydrates. So you don't know what a carbohydrate is.
You're going to have to educate yourself a little bit. This would be a good slide to look at
over and over again, and maybe even screenshot it and pause the video. There's tons of information
on the internet about this, so don't worry about that. But look at that, eat more meat,
more low-carb foods, and at the bottom with this red on the bottom, you're not eating any of that stuff.
So really get your glucose levels down. Here's a really nice picture that I pulled off the
internet about what you'd have for a breakfast, maybe a green drink, maybe some eggs, maybe meat for
breakfast, maybe an omelette, and maybe an avocado, and then you can see some different choices.
Good to say, this is a very hardy way to eat. Now if you're addicted to sweets, you're not going
to like this diet, at least for the first few weeks, because you're really cutting them out.
All your diets, this is just my recommendation. All your diets, if you're going on a ketogenic
like diet, it might be a good idea for your spouse and your family to go on a very similar diet. So
you're not tempted by very junk food and cookies and cakes and stuff, and you're on a ketogenic
diet. It could be very miserable, but if there's nothing in your house, and this is what you're eating,
this could be very fulfilling, very hardy, very warm. It's a really comfort food. So ketogenic
diets is an easy one to do, really. This is that low-carb diet. So if your genes point to that,
and I say we're going on a ketogenic like diet, this is what you're going to. All right, I hope this
helps, and stick to it. Remember, feel free to search the internet for other things on a ketogenic
diet and more things on our website about it too. Thanks so much.